one of the rising stars of French
politics Gabriel tal is now France's
youngest prime minister the 34-year-old
took over from Elizabeth Bourne at a
ceremony in Paris after being appointed
by the French President Emanuel
maon the youngest president in the
history of the Republic has appointed
the youngest prime minister in the
history of the Republic and in this I
see a sign of audacity and change and
also a symbol of confidence in
youth atal began his career with the
Socialist Party but joined macron's
Centrist movement a year before macron
was elected in 2017 his career has
accelerated under the president from
government spokesperson and budget
minister to his recent post as education
minister in which he controversially
banned ayas in
schools in appointing Gabriel atal
president mro will be hoping to
revitalize his government and turn the
page on what has been a very difficult
and challenging year
from months of pension reform protests
to divisions in the president's party
over a new immigration law macr is
clearly Keen for a fresh start but the
change of prime minister doesn't change
the fact that the president doesn't have
a majority in the French Parliament and
pushing ahead with his reform agenda
won't get any
easier the difficulty is that when you
want to push through major reforms you
need a majority I don't see how he's
going to achieve this so it's a cosmetic
change for PR purp in the fth Republic
and particularly under Emanuel Macon
it's effectively the El that decides
everything so it's a new actor in the
same role atal will now Forge ahead with
the president's reforms and oversee the
Paris Olympic Games he'll also need to
rebuild trust with the public ahead of
June's EU elections and Stave off the
rising threat from far-right parties
opinion poll suggests that atal is one
of France's most popular politicians but
he'll be all too aware that in politics
things can change fast Natasha Butler Al
jazer
Paris make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer